A typical defense against DDoS, is for
a company to buy more servers or
bandwidth.
However, DDoS attacks can be
amplified to make such defense very,
very expensive.
Here's one example.
On the internet, there are many so
called open recursive DNS servers.
These are DNS servers that any
machine on the internet can query.
A typical DNS query is to look up
the IP address of a domain name.
The DNS also allows query for
the so called large TXT record
of a domain that includes a lot
of details of the domain.
Even including organization note,
description, information and so on.
The point is that the size of the query
response can be more than 1,500 bytes.
So, here's how this amplified
distributed reflective attack works.
The attacker instructs the bots to query
the open recursive DNS
servers on the internet.
And in the query, the source of
the query is spoofed as victim's IP.
Meaning that the response will
be sent back to the victim
instead of to the bot.
And the query itself is for
the Large TXT record.
Because the query is for
the Large TXT record,
the response will be
at least 1,500 bytes.
And again, because the query is spoofed,
as from the victim,
the response will be sent to the victim.
Because there are many bots, and
each bot can query multiple
recursive DNS servers.
The victim as a result will get
many many responses each with
at least 1500 bytes.
Therefore with just a couple thousand
bots participating in the attack,
the victim can get several
gigabytes of traffic.